hello everyone today I'm going to show
you one of the most beautiful games in
chess history and although the game
itself is pretty great one move in
particular got it the title the American
Beauty and before I show you the game I
would just like to say a couple of words
about the players so the player with the
white pieces is Stefan Levitsky and
lewinsky was a strong Russian chess
master he won a couple of tournaments
and in 1911 he won a very strong
tournament the Russian championship so
it was a Russian national champion and
frank marshall is the well most of you
know him for his martial attack a
variation in the rule opus but it was
actually a very strong player he was the
United States champion from 1909 to 1936
so he held the title for 27 years and
yeah Levitsky also was known for
introducing the Levitsky attack the d4
d5 Bishop to g5 move but today Eliska is
probably most known in the world for
losing this game against Frank Frank
Marshall so ok let's see the game
Levitsky is white and Frank Marshall is
whack so we have d 4e 6 e 4 D 5
so not the right move order but it's
transposed into the French defense
Knight to c3 c5 Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 there it captures only 5 e captures
on d5 Bishop to e2 Knight to f6 white
castles Bishop to e7 Bishop to g5
Marshall castles D captures on c5 Bishop
to e6 and now nice to d4 we have Bishop
captures on c5 Knight captures an e6 and
F captures any six Bishop to g4 Queen 36
protecting that pawn on e6 Levitsky
plays Bishop to h3 moving him away from
the knight and here Marshall plays rook
a to d8 and if you look at this position
you can already feel that white did did
at least something wrong as all of
blacks pieces are fully developed and he
has this nice nice open F file and while
white rocks are pretty much doing
nothing and well this bishop on h3 is
looking pretty you know pretty weird so
white lies Queen to d2 connecting his
works with the B for painting the night
and he loved it he captures the night
not the best of moves but well he didn't
really like the idea of Marshall going
night to d4 Knight to e4 and this bishop
and g5 wasn't really doing anything much
so he captured Bishop on f6 rook
captures an s6 rook to d1 Queen to c5
brushing that c3 square
Queen TV to and by playing this quantity
to Leviticus giving up upon here but his
queen is pretty much useless and e2 so
Marshall captures the knight on c3 and
wins the point B captures on c3 and
Queen captures on c3 and rook captures
on d5 so with this little trick Louis
key wins the pawn back but Marshall
plays a nice to d4 attacking the Queen
and here we have Queen to h5 attacking
this rook on e8 and here Marshall plays
rook the f8 and Marshall is threatening
to capture the pawn on f2 because for
example this rook is attacked if Lewis
key plays something like road to d7 den
Broek to f2 is completely winning after
rook captures Queen to be 1 and this
will be made so in this position when
Marshall played rook to f8 Louis K
actually plays the the strongest move
the move the engine is recommending he
plays rook to e5 and in this position
well sadly for Louis key this rook to f2
move is still pretty much available
because if drew captures in Quinta a1
will give us the same result but it's
Marshall played rook captures an s2 here
then while millions of books today would
be missing this beautiful game that
Marshall played so Marshall had another
idea
he plays rook to h6 attacking the Queen
and well he's actually not attacking the
Queen the Queen will move but he's
actually attacking this bishop on h3 the
bishop can be defended this Queen play
something like Queen to g4 then this
Knight to f3 check will be well pretty
bad for white as the Queen will capture
this rook so after Marshall plays rook
to h6 the whiskey plays 20 g5 is to
protect the route and now Marshall
captures rook captures on h3 and of
course in this position white can't
capture the rook as he would be punished
by Knight to f3 checks picking up the
Queen and in this position fluidity
fries rook the c5 and well this position
is completely winning for black and
black has a number of ways to win this
game but Marshall finds the most
beautiful way to do it and Marshall
place between to g3 and this is the move
that awarded this game the title the
American beauty and it is said that
after this move was played well the
spectators shout the board with gold
coins now whether this is true or not I
can't really say some say it is some say
it isn't of course I would like to think
it is it's a great story but the general
opinion is that well those those were
probably wagers because people you know
bet on this chess game and they put
their money on the whiskey so let's see
what happens here obviously what can
capture the Queen with the F pawn he can
capture the Queen with the H phone and
he can capture the Queen with his queen
so let's see what happens if he plays F
captures and g3 well he gets this nice
to be to check the only move is into h1
because of the rock and the f8 soak into
h1 and rook to f1 is checkmate so let's
see what happens if this pawn on H
captures
queen well then simply nice to a2 is
checkmate immediately so only move left
is what happens if the Queen captures
the Queen so we have Queen captures on
g3 we have Knight to e2 check King to h1
we have Knight captures the Queen and g3
this h-bomb cannot take the knight
because it's pinned and well if this
pawn captures the knight then route to
f1 is checkmate and only move after
black captures the Queen is played King
back to G 1 but now Knight captures on
f1 and after DG captures on h3 simply
night to d2 and well black is up a piece
and completely winning so after Queen to
g3 lewinsky resigned and it was all over
and well there it is for you to see the
American Beauty I really hope you
enjoyed this game and especially this
move and as usual you can check out two
of my previous videos here and I would
just like to say for the end of this
video
tomorrow I will be having my chess quiz
I hope most of you will be able to
participate and later today I will post
a video with you know some more detailed
rules and I've chosen a chess set which
will be awarded to the winner so I will
show its chess set as well so until then
thank you all for watching thanks for
your time and feel free to comment on
this game and I'll see you soon